they've been here for over 30 years now
some 3,000 Afghan refugees live in the
bats ear jamaran camp in the Iranian
province of c'mon Madame ghulami is
grateful to the Iranians for their help
but the widow doesn't see much of a
future in Iran the family can barely
make ends meet so her children have to
work dangerous jobs her son broke his
leg doing so I was 10 when I got here my
kids have never seen Afghanistan we
don't have the money to travel there and
the security situation is so terrible
that our relatives have now also fled to
Iran about 1 million Afghan refugees are
registered in Iran many of them have
lived here for decades because they're
only allowed to take menial work in are
barred from attending university many
are frustrated but none of them are
willing to say that on camera in this
settlement I've warned I spend time I
will I don't know the real life of the
the situation is even more frustrating
for an estimated 2 million undocumented
refugees living here illegally they work
on the black market mostly on
construction sites
despite this for about a year now
they've been able to get medical
attention and sent their children to
school that's also partially thanks to
funding supplied by international aid
organizations and the EU it's in schools
like this one here in the cabmen region
of Iran where Afghan refugee children
can study together with Iranian children
and that means it's not only the
document at once but also the
undocumented children that are studying
here that is crucial because it's the
majority of the children that here get a
future get an education not just for
Iran but also for Afghanistan and it
gives a guarantee to their parents that
they cannot be deported EU officials
believe that if conditions for Refugees
in Iran improve they'll be less likely
to try to make the dangerous journey to
Europe
Chris Sicilian eaters the EU
commissioner for humanitarian aid says
closer cooperation with Iran is
essential he's convinced that the
refugees would benefit greatly why not
the Afghan refugees stay very close to
their home and maybe in the next time
future time when we'll see peace in
their land to make an appropriation
process in order to return in their
homes this is the best scenario still a
anita's knows it's a long-term and
ambitious project a slump in global oil
prices along with growing Iranian public
discontent about so many refugees in the
country is putting local authorities
under pressure it's by news even more
year in her mantra nadi it's very likely
the EU would notice the difference if we
did not support refugees here last year
there was a wave of refugees heading
into Europe but without the efforts of
the Islamic Republic it would have been
even worse
Varya would ye mat-su sandwich or would
kill me for that Christmas Tilly Anita's
announced the EU would double funding
for Iranian refugee aid to 12.5 million
euro this year but that still isn't
enough because many refugees here
continue to dream of making the journey
to Europe